president biden is looking to reboot his
agenda to try and save his failing
presidency biden now road testing his
economic message with a trip to ohio
today and for good reason his approval
is dismal in a new quinnipiac poll just
37 percent of voters think he's doing a
good job
and inflation topping the list of issues
americans are most worried about
biden doing his best to put a positive
spin
we're bringing manufacturing jobs back
taking supply chains back home from
abroad so we have a better jobs and
lower prices
all right i'll start with you dana
with president biden at what is it a 37
percent approval rating i mean does
anyone believe
that he can turn this around well so i
keep trying to see what they're going to
announce ahead of the state of the union
to try to make us believe that there is
a pivot coming and i just every day i
give great ideas and nothing ever comes
of it
i think that his trips to ohio and to
virginia are considered these do no harm
type of trips because he can't hurt the
democrats in those states any more than
they already are he lost ohio by eight
in virginia i think a similar amount um
arizona georgia new hampshire and nevada
now if he were to go to those states
those are the swing states where the
senate races really matter he would be
seen as like a force for good for
helping democrats but he's not going
there why not
because he would be seen as hurting
somebody like a senator mark kelly who's
trying to run for reelection or raphael
warnock remember what happened when he
went to georgia with kamala harris and
all of a sudden stacey abrams had a
scheduling conflict and she couldn't
attend a speech on the most important
issue that she works on voting rights so
i think that they're having him go out
on the road because if you remember a
month ago they said the problem with his
approval ratings is that they don't
communicate well enough and then he
wanted to get out and see the people and
that's what they're trying to do here
we'll see if it works i don't i'm
skeptical all right jesse let's assume
that he's talking about infrastructure
in ohio do americans want to hear about
infrastructure we only like
infrastructure when the construction is
finished we hate construction during
construction it's just a bunch of
traffic and hammering we like when the
politician comes and cuts the ribbon
when it's over i love the giant scissors
but until the giant scissors cuts the
ribbon we hate it plus none of these
things are even off the ground yet none
of the money's been dispersed they
haven't even put a shovel in the dirt so
what's going to be 3 10 15 years later
before anything happens dead the problem
is well you probably will be by the way
you eat
the problem is his economic message is
jammed up because you can say oh yeah
wages are up but inflation kills that
you could say the market's up but it's
real choppy you could say jobs are up
but not to where they were before covet
started so all he does is talk about the
good things and he doesn't ever address
the bad things so when the americans
hear that they think this guy's clueless
well with inflation being 27 percent of
americans think it's the number one
issue greg i mean does this guy have any
credibility does he have any hope i was
thinking about this
how the inflation as an issue is like
crime and that it becomes a result of
this changing class division
the left in media and politics and
entertainment to them inflation just
means their foie gras at chapini is 65
instead of 55 or their lift tickets i
just went up a bit in aspen but that's
not going to stop the rich democrats
from skiing basically inflation is an
absorbable cost for a rich liberal's
fantasy they can pay it just the same
way they can protect themselves from
crime meanwhile everybody else can't
everybody else who actually looks at
prices on products tries to get stuff on
sale inflation isn't some invisible
byproduct of big government
yep all right geraldo shouldn't it be
making some changes in the white house
with the staff oh yeah they should
definitely who should he get rid of the
the the chief of staff ron claim yeah
clean okay get him out of there but i i
have a different take on biden and ohio
which is my home state right now
lorraine is a city west of cleveland a
storied
port city where they used to build
thousand foot long ships big steel mill
up the river there deep water river uh
this announcement was electrifying today
that he's gonna spend two billion
dollars of the build back better not to
build back better the infrastructure
to for a submarine construction base
there that's right three four thousand
permanent employees that's good uh you
know
lorraine was a place where many puerto
ricans came after world war ii to build
ships so this is a great thing for the
great lakes if it happens uh jesse's
point it is well taken you know it's one
thing to talk about it or to dig the
first shovel
but if it but the people on the rai my
radio show wtam are and cleveland this
morning were very very electrified they
were excited that this project was i'm
happy for them hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else